they're all happy and it's and i know
why they're happy
and it's it it's there are three kind of
things that i think
are that that make them happy and i
don't really aspire to them which is
weird but
um family community religion and i think
that
i think that like uh if people build
these inner circles
out outward they have themselves and
they have their family then they have
their community and they have religion
or it might
be religion might be the closest thing
but those are the things now i'm not
religious
but i understand why it works and
religious people tend to be incredibly
nice
and and and forgiving and will help you
and and part of being religious
is actually helping people being
charitable that's the same thing and it
also bleeds into their family and their
community
[Music]
so i really like the title of the book
because the plus the idea basically that
there are positive things out there that
you can aspire to that you can kind of
incorporate your life and everything
else
um we've talked about this a little bit
on your show but
one of the things that i'm kind of
amazed by right now is that
a certain set of people and i would say
generally politically they're on the
right they are
actually much happier than the the
people on the left
um and i don't think that has to do
solely with politics
are you with me on that do you see a
fundamental reason that even when i
just just the fox crew that i've become
friendly with so you
and dana and and uh tucker and hannity
like
i from what i know i i i know you the
best
person but like everyone's happy they're
all happy and it's and i know why
they're happy
and it's it it's there are three kind of
things that i think
are that that make them happy and i
don't really aspire to them which is
weird but
um family community religion and i think
that
i think that like uh if people build
these
inner circles out outward they have
themselves and they have their family
then they have their community and they
have religion or it might be religion
might be the closest thing
but those are the things now i'm not
religious but i understand
why it works and religious people
tend to be incredibly nice and and and
forgiving and will help you
and and part of being religious is
actually helping people being charitable
that's the same thing and it also bleeds
into their family and their community
there is a certain you know possibility
or potential for intolerance
intolerance as you know among religions
and that's always something to be
watched out for
but it provides a structure for people
so i think but it's true it's like
uh everybody's very happy like i i am uh
i'm probably
more uh uh i i think i i swing between
poles in terms of happiness and
unhappiness
because i'm neurotic so i i would say
that i'm at my happiest point in my life
but that's still not as happy as they
are because of my neurosis
and anxiety prevents me from jumping
completely into the happiness pool
you know but greg as a self-help guru i
can tell you now
uh that it's it's that neurosis but it's
that neurosis that
that's sort of creating why what you do
works because
whenever i'm on on the greg gutfeld show
when
if we text after you always say the same
thing to me if it's a good show you go
we got all the serious stuff out at the
beginning
and then we had fun and i think that
that's what people are responding to
so it's like your show i'm sure you know
the numbers i mean you are
crushing it crushing the late night
people right now
and it's like they're the ones that have
30 writers
they've got you know millions and
millions of dollars worth of budgets and
all that stuff
and they're miserable and unfunny how
many people work on your show
eight maybe and and in terms of writing
that show
uh and we used to do this every night
with red eye with roughly the same crew
and it it it's uh like i write my
monologue and then tom and holly
and this other kid gene will will work
on the segments and the graphics i
better not leave anybody out and of
course cat
does her thing which is really good and
tyrus writes his stuff
it's um and it's naturally funny
and smart and you aren't having you
aren't sitting in a air-conditioned room
with 13 people
who are all making six figures ordering
in let's order in and
write 40 more jokes for kimmel's
monologue uh
nobody right i mean i'm opening myself
up when i say nobody writes my jokes
because that's like we can tell greg
but i always start with like okay i have
a serious point to make
and then you work your way through that
and then at the end there are these
jokes that come up absurdities and i
instead of just leaving them out i put
them in and it always helps to be
it's you know to have targets that are
hilarious i mean cnn never gets old
you know as long as you have chris cuomo
and don lemon i'm gonna have a monologue
and uh or brian stelter i mean these are
the gifts
that you know keep on slobbering
well that's the thing because it's like
if you look at the cnn crew
not only do they all seem miserable and
we can and the lies and all that stuff
but like you guys are having fun like
there doesn't seem to be any level of
fun there and i'm not saying the news
has to be
fun per se but i think it does it does
color something else beneath it or
something like that you know
think about like the daily show with jon
stewart was having fun during that
period
i don't see that anywhere even on comedy
central you really don't see any fun
i i've said this to you before i always
use i call it the dean wermer effect
that like for the longest time in animal
house the republicans were always dean
wermer
and everybody else right pluto and the
and delta house
we the whole goal of you know when
andrew was alive and
and uh i was working at huffington post
was flipping so
yeah so the republicans would be at some
point would become
delta house and deliver and the left
would become
uh dean wermer and that's what's
happening you know this you left dean
wermer
and you're watching this i think i'm
curious about how you feel about matt
taibi
because i feel really guilty about the
all the times
that i kind of dismissed him as just a
left-wing
the way he dismissed me i'm sure or he
didn't maybe know who i was
but i see him now and i go like he's
dave rubin he's two months away from you
becoming right well i i feel like it you
know it's it's like a little pat on my
back it's like oh
all of the these people now are just
saying what i said years ago so
yeah you know it's like when you're when
you're ahead of the curve you somehow
feel behind it in a way when it starts
getting to the moment of of uh
mainstream you're like ah
yeah but it's good like i don't i i
don't know that he
he knows me specifically but i'm like
yeah you're just writing the same exact
stuff i said four years ago
that's really great you know yeah you
see that though you see that with brett
weinstein you see that with his wife
when you listen to that what they're
what they go through and by the way
probably the most i guess disturbing
thing about this last couple of months
is that how
right brett was about um
what's the name of this college green um
evergreen evergreen that
evergreen has gotten out of the zoo it's
out of the zoo
and yeah and it's all over the place and
it's like he said that was gonna happen
and i am trying to maintain a positive
like this is not gonna get any worse
because
there's no slippery slope with this you
either either have law and order or you
don't you got to stop this
but so far he's he and his brother have
been pretty
uh uh dead on on this stuff makes me
very nervous
so for a guy like you that doesn't want
i know you don't want the whole
system to collapse but i think you also
i think we're probably similar in this
way you understand
the why it's collapsing what do you see
is the way that we can kind of get out
of this thing
well i i mean i'm gonna sound like a
broken record because i am
i do agree with donald trump that
fake news is the enemy of the people i
mean i don't know if you could find a
clearer statement than tear down the
wall maybe
because almost all of these things that
are happening to us right now
tend to be these psychological conflicts
that are
ginned up and i think if you go to any
serious issue where there is an issue
you could talk about
police and policing communities serious
issue does the media add or subtract to
it
it's a negative it's a minus it's not a
plus the more that the american public
understands how to perceive what's going
on on television at cable television
and not to trust it the better off we're
going to be i think the first thing we
have to do is understand
that this is not our friend that this
this this is a
this is a machinery of division that's
trying to get us to eat each other alive
and they and then they don't see it like
you see on cnn going you know we
this what's happening yesterday you know
what's happening in portland is
you know we don't condone it but it's
being exaggerated
you know by the pouncing right-wing
media no they found a
dead body in in minneapolis and they
burned out you know uh
pawn shop that ain't pouncing that's a
corpse
so i mean it is i think that the first
thing is realization
that this institution is gone it's your
enemy
and and uh and i and fake news is the
enemy of the people
sounds so you know it sounds so trumpian
but it actually god we knew this right
we always it's like like if you and you
by the way
you know this i know this specifically
because
anytime anybody writes about you it's
never
right it's never it's like you you get
you know i've been written about i don't
know
a bunch of times and if the person loves
your show it's going to be great
but if they're coming from a liberal
institution in which they have editors
they can't compliment you they can't see
your point of view
they can't even empathize so they'll go
like dave rubin claims to be a
traditional liberal who became
disillusioned with the progressive left
what he likes to call in a mocking
manner regressive
we met dave and but and he's like and
then there's like
six or seven cutting remarks and then
some comment from somebody who doesn't
like you
well here's the thing about dave that
you probably aren't aware it's like
and so it builds and you go like wow
this whole story
was just designed to take me down and
it's not true i didn't say
that i've had instances with reputable
journalists where i go that didn't
happen
that didn't happen and then if you end
up on twitter calling people out you
could be there all day
you know and i've like i've called out
four or five people and they've
retracted others don't
but um you know it's if you if you are
the object of a story
you know this you knew that you know how
this works they seek a narrative
they need to tell a story if the beach
doesn't have a shark
it's not a story so they need to have a
shark at that beach if you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell